DEMOCRAT FOR PRESIDENT LAST YEAR
AND NEW YORK CITY MAYOR THIS
YEAR SAYS HE HAS LEFT THE PARTY
IS NOW REGISTERED INDEPENDENT.
HE WRITES, BREAKING UP WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FEELS LIKE THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
THIS COMES AS HIS NEW BOOK SET
FOR RELEASE TOMORROW, FORWARD
NOTES ON THE FUTURE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY, ANDREW YANG JOINS US
NOW.
WHY LEAVE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
YOU RAN FOR PRESIDENT AND MAYOR
AS A DEMOCRAT.
>> I HAVE BEEN A DEMOCRAT FOR 26
YEARS, ANDERSON.
IF THERE IS A THEME TONIGHT THAT
I SAW IT WAS THAT POLARIZATION
IS AT RECORD HIGH LEVELS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
POLITICAL STRESS IS APPROACHING
CIVIL WAR LEVELS.
AND THE QUESTION IS, HOW COULD
WE BRING THE TEMPERATURE OF THE
COUNTRY DOWN?
AND I WANT TO BE THE
METAPHORICAL WET BLANKET FOR THE
COUNTRY.
I AM BRINGING NOT JUST,
HOPEFULLY, SOME KIND OF SOOTHING
WORDS, BUT AN ACTUAL POLICY FIX
THAT WILL HELP BRING THE
TEMPERATURE OF THE COUNTRY DOWN
BY CHANGING THE POLITICAL
INCENTIVE OF OUR LEADERS BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IF YOU ARE A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS YOUR JOB IS TO PLEASE
THE 20% MOST EXTREME ON EITHER
FLANK OF THE POPULATION.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS CHANGE IT
SO YOU HAVE TO APPEAL TO FIFTH
1% OF THE POPULATION AND THAT
WOULD BRING THE TEMPERATURE DOWN
VERY, VERY QUICKLY, ALMOST
OVERNIGHT.
>> SOUNDS LIKE YOU WANT TO BE A
WEIGHTED BLANKET THAT IS MORE
COMFORTING.
>> YEAH.
I WANT TO BE THE THING THAT
PHARMACEUTICALS PEOPLE AND MAKES
THEM HAPPY.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE SPLITS
OVER INFRASTRUCTURE, SOCIAL
SAFETY NET, I MEAN, IF YOU'RE AN
INDEPENDENT, WHO DO YOU THINK
HAS THE BETTER ARGUMENT BETWEEN
PROGRESSIVES WITH THEIR
$3.5 TRILLION PITCH FOR
SPENDING, MODERATES WHO WANT TO
SEE THE NUMBER CUT IN HALF AT
LEAST?
>> I WANT TO SOLVE PROBLEMS,
ANDERSON.
I HAPPY TO AGREE WITH ONE SIDE'S
APPROACH WHEN IT COMES TO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT WAS A BIPARTISAN BILL AT
LEAST IN THE SENATE.
BUT THE QUESTION IS HOW CAN WE
ACTUALLY MAKE OUR SYSTEM WORK
FOR US, THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY AGAIN, BECAUSE WE CAN
SENSE IT'S NOT WORKING THAT WELL
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE BEING SET UP TO FAIL.
THE INCENTIVES ARE SUCH THAT
CONGRESS HAS A NATIONAL APPROVAL
RATING OF 28%.
THE RE-ELECTION RATE OF MEMBERS
IS 92%.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO AFEEL TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION.
THEY JUST HAVE TO APPEAL TO THE
20% ON EITHER SIDE.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO CHANGE
AND I AM STARTING A POPULAR
MOVEMENT TO HELP IMPLEMENT OPEN
PRIMARIES AND RANK CHOICE VOTING
THAT WOULD IMPROVE OUR
LEGISLATORS' INCENTIVES AND
REDUCE THE POLARIZATION THAT
THREATENS TO TEAR OUR COUNTRY
PART.
>> A LOT OF LEGISLATURES, HOW
LIKELY DO YOU THINK IT IS TO
CHANGE VOTING LIKE THAT?
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE NOW
INCREASINGLY BILLS IN
LEGISLATURES AROUND THE COUNTRY
TO MAKE VOTING MORE DIFFICULT.
>> I AM HAPPY TO SAY THAT THIS
IS ALREADY BEEN DONE IN ONE RET
STATE, ALASKA.
AND ALL WE NEED IS ENOUGH
AMERICANS TO COME TOGETHER AND
SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
WE ARE SICK OF BEING PITTED
AGAINST EACH OTHER, SICK OF THE
DYSFUNCTION AND TO PUSH BALLOT
INITIATIVES THAT REQUIRE A LOT
OF AMERICANS SIGNING IN 24
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY FROM
MISSOURI TO MASSACHUSETTS.
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, I WATCH NOT
JUST YOUR SHOW, ANDERSON, BUT
ALL OF US CAN FEEL THE POLITICAL
TENSION RISING AND RISING.
AND THE QUESTION IS, WHAT CAN WE
ACTUALLY DO TO FIX IT?
IF ENOUGH OF US GET TOGETHER WE
CAN MAKE THIS HAPPEN STATE BY
STATE.
YOU DON'T NEED CONGRESS OR STATE
LEGISLATURES IN HALF THE STATES
IN THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU WROTE ABOUT WHAT IT WAS
LIKE TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT AS IT
WAS LIKE HAVING A BIRTHDAY EVERY
DAY AND IT BECAME SORT OF A
BRAND THAT YOU WERE PROMOTING.
I AM WONDERING THE RUN FOR
MAYOR, YOU RAN FOR MAYOR OF NEW
YORK, LOST IN THE PRIMARY.
DO YOU REGRET RUNNING FOR MAYOR?
>> IT WAS A PRIVILEGE MEET SOG
MANY PEOPLE ALL OVER NEW YORK
CITY.
WE SET A RECORD FOR NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUAL DONORS TO NEW YORK
M
MAYORAL CAMPAIGN.
MY ONLY REGRET IS I AM NOT IN
POSITION TO DO MORE GOOD IN NEW
YORK.
NOW I FEEL LIKE THIS CAN DO SO
MUCH GOOD FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
BY PROPOSING A REAL POLICY
SOLUTION THAT WILL REDUCE
POLARIZATION IN THIS COUNTRY AND
GET US TO WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY
HAVE DINNER WITH OUR FAMILIES
AGAIN AROUND THE HOLIDAYS.
>> ANDREW YANG, APPRECIA